reste au brésil dans notre édition avec
fanny lothaire bonjour fanny êtes à rio
avant de parler d'économie parlons
géopolitique quelle est la position du
président molson haro sur sur cette
guerre l'ambiguïté
à la position de jean ibos hoarau est
très clair ne surtout en prendre aucune
depuis les prémices de ce conflit gerbe
sun araw a voulu à dire rester neutre un
choix de vocabulaire qui a fait grincer
des dents une grande partie des
brésiliens mais surtout jusque dans les
coulisses du pouvoir et de la
représentation du brésil à l'onu et qui
a voté comme une grande majorité de la
communauté internationale le 2 mars
dernier en faveur de la résolution et
qui condamnait à la russie même le vice
président le général hamilton mort on a
tenu à s'exprimer a condamné l invasion
russe il a très vite été désavoué par
jaillir rossonero en clair seuls le
président brésilien peut s'exprimer sur
le conflit faut dire que j'aille
rossonero est assez proche de vladimir
poutine il l'a toujours est très admiré
va l'aider marketing qui a pris sa
défense lors de l'épineux sujet de la
souveraineté sur la forêt amazonienne
alors le brésil est très très loin
évidemment du débat et du conflit en
ukraine mais cette position ambiguë sur
une crise majeure comme celle ci peut
l'isoler encore plus sur la scène
internationale on en vient aux
conséquences économiques fanny quelles
sont elles
et je veux la paix et surtout pas à
tirer les conséquences avait dit gerbaud
sonar haut et parlait évidemment a des
conséquences économiques il faut dire
que le brésil importe du blé et du
pétrole comme la communauté européenne
mais surtout être des engrais des
fertilisants si précieux au secteur
agricole le puissant secteur agricole
brésilien du nitrate et du potassium 70%
des fertilisants brésiliens viennent de
l'extérieur de l'étranger et la russie
et un de ses principaux partenaires
seulement le géant russe elle vient de
demander de suspendre les exportations
d'engrais de fertilisants ce qui
inquiète le puissant lobby agricole et 6
mais surtout les brésiliens car les prix
des denrées alimentaires déjà très
impactées par la pandémie pourrait
encore plus augmenté